foreign
started here I'm just going to start
with some introductory slides
and then on the tender will get into the
sample lesson
so
hold on a second
all right
thank you for your patience we're going
to do a free sample class today from the
Ai and machine learning boot camp from
Caltech Center for technology and
management education
and this will cover the topic of
classification methods and machine
learning
and
I'm attendra who will give himself a
better introduction in the short while
when he starts this lesson but it's an
extreme experience and he now reminds me
he has more than 4 500 hours of
experience and training
um
is that correct
and uh
has delivered training
um on many ml uh AI Concepts so
this will be a great example of the kind
of instruction you get with I'm going to
start by uh introducing the curriculum
just for a moment so you see where this
lies in the overall
program
and then the live lesson
and we'll do a q a and I'll mention a
little bit about the caltex boot camp at
the very end
the curriculum for the Caltech AI meml
Boot Camp starts off with an induction
session orientation sessions
then you go into the basics of
artificial intelligence
basic underlying Concepts and move into
python training then learn how to apply
Python and data science
and then in machine learning which is
the module from which this sample
lesson's taken uh you learn about the um
algorithms and methodologies for uh
models to be able to adapt to new data
that comes in then a module on deep
learning tools Keras and tensorflow and
advanced deep learning and Machine
Vision
and then a Capstone project
and you then earn your certificate
Capstone project ties together
everything you've learned in the program
so that it is something you can show off
to uh employers or potential employers
along the way you can take the electives
also on statistics Essentials NLP
natural language processing and speech
recognition reinforcement learning and
master classes from Caltech
instructors so that they'll share topics
and Ai and ml with you all of those are
included in the program so
um I'm going to let uh
I'm a tendra
Gus oops
discuss these next two slides before he
shares his screen
thanks Stuart
so hello everyone here
um I'm gonna just explain you about
classification methods when we talk
about machine learning uh under machine
learning we have something called
supervised learning where we have such
data sets where uh the the input has
been given and the corresponding output
has also been given and that's called
supervised learning and under supervised
learning there is a method called
classification method and this method
basically uh helps you in terms of
classifying the data into one of the
categories to give you a little
perspective on that suppose you work for
a bank and you are into lending business
and you want to understand if a loan has
to be given to a particular customer or
not
so there's a way of looking at it you
should look for the bank balances you
should look for the transactional
records any loan that they have taken in
the past any any kind of Emi which got
bounced and a check got bounced and then
combining all these inputs you come to a
conclusion where you have you you should
give loan to a particular customer or
not because it might it might result
into a bad debt so classification
technique helps you in terms of taking
these inputs and classifying customers
into one of the class whether they will
default on a loan or not
so that's where classification comes and
and and if you look at into it it's the
same analysis I can take into HR domain
and I can think of uh among all the
employees who are working who will
resign from the company that I can term
it as attrition analysis so that again
is a classification technique or it
could be
it could be you want to understand if a
transaction is fraudulent or not or not
then you want to use a machine learning
algorithm to automate this entire
process of identifying a fraudulent
transaction so that customers do not
lose their money
so whenever you have such kind of
problem where your output requires one
of the class to be predicted we do
classification
and and there are different
different types of classification
algorithms which are there we have
multi-class binary classification binary
classification is basically when you
have only two classes yes or no success
or failure multi-class could be where
you are predicting an outcome which has
more than two classes
and for for this classification
technique there are set of algorithms
which are available
some algorithms might work for a
particular problem some might not so
what we do over there we try different
algorithms at least two three we try on
the daytime we see which one is working
well and then we get on with with that
particular model in terms of fine tuning
it one of the model that is mentioned
over here is nail base another is
decision tree random Forest logistic
regression cane and these are all
example of classification algorithm so
idea is this that you understand these
algorithms and then you are able to
implement on the data that's what the
whole idea is
so
at any time you want to start sharing
your screen please go ahead on the
Tinder
sure
so I'll share now
so uh I'm gonna give you a uh an
overview of what we are doing over here
we're gonna I'm gonna explain you
classification one of the model I'm
picking up I'm gonna explain you the
concept and then we will quickly
Implement on the data and for that I'm
using our LMS on our LMS we have our lab
so once I log into
LMS which will be given to you guys also
I go to my lab I start my lab I have my
classification presentation with me
which which is generally shared with
participants as well and this is what we
are discussing here so this is our lab
here we will learn and we will Implement
so both the stuff will happen
simultaneously and I was talking about
uh some of the classification Technique
we discussed about uh we I just
explained to you that there are multiple
algorithm one of them is new based
theorem which is pretty interesting
we'll discuss about that another
algorithm that you should learn is
support Vector machines along with your
tree based model decision tree random
forest or it could be boosting
algorithms like a gradient boosting
algorithm extreme gradient boosting and
there might be such a libraries also
which will make your job easier one of
the library which is pretty useful for
boosting algorithm is called cat boost
so those are the algorithm that you
should actually learn now when you talk
about classifier I explained to you the
idea is this that you have been given
class is like you might have certain
people who have who have defaulted on a
loan some people who have not defaulted
on a loan and what you want to do is you
want to build a classifier and you can
say that okay anyone who's above this
line will default and alone Circle
represents defaulters and anyone who is
below the line will not default on a
loan those are the people who are
regular customer and and they they are
pretty good and I might have features
like say age of the person and I might
have
I might have here a annual income that
they maintain something like that and
the idea is to come up with this
classifier
and there are different types of
classifier there could be a linear
classifier there could be a non-linear
classifier
one of the classifier that we are
discussing over here is called new base
classifier which is based on name-based
theorem
and the new base theorem is a
conditional probability that we talk
about and base theorem States this this
is based on a conditional conditional
probability which kind of looks like a
little complex but I'll simplify it for
you so it says here probability of an
event a
given B has taken place is given as this
particular formula over here
which is probability of B given a which
is also termed as likelihoods
then probability of a which is called
class prior probability
then probability of B is called
predictor prior probability which is
this
now in case if you are wondering what
this probability is all about and what
kind of problem we are solving here let
me give you couple of examples and then
prompt it will be entirely clear to you
so what we are doing over here is
if I take an example over here if
suppose I received thousands of email
and out of 1000 emails I know 600 of
them
are regular email
and 400 of them are spam
this is how I have got my data sorted
once we received the emails we manually
classified them into regular emails and
spam and I got to know out of 1000
emails that I have in my inbox 600 are
regular 400 are spam and now what
happens is is that tomorrow suppose a
new email comes which has a word called
free in it
and I want to know if this this email
that I have received which has one of
the word it will have multiple words but
I'm just focusing on one word if it has
a word free in it will it be a
spam email or can I classify that as a
regular email and that's where this this
new base theorem is coming into the
picture what we can do with this theorem
I'm just expanding the theorem that I
have just shown you the formula it says
what is the probability that the given
email is a spam email
provided a word free
has occurred in it
that's what we do over here we calculate
a probability what is the probability
that a given word given given email is a
spam email
already free has occurred in that
particular email so this is what we are
calculating over here and that's the
same formula that I have spoken about
earlier P of a provided B has taken
place and this is given equal to
probability of
free happening in any of the spam emails
so now what I do I go back to my
database and I say of all the spams that
I got 400 of them
calculate the total number of words that
I have total number of words
that I have total number of unique words
in my spam
need not to be unique total number of
words in my
spam emails and how many times
how many times free is occurring in that
particular
spam set of data
and this is called likelihood which is
coming
into the into the later this second part
of the
equation over here this is your how many
times free is happening in all the spam
emails that we have got that's what we
are calculating as for likelihood and
then we multiply this with what is the
probability that any email would be spam
so same formula we are just expanding
and then I can calculate
what is the probability that the given
email is a spam email and with the same
logic I can also calculate what is the
probability that the given email is a
regular email provided a word free has
already taken place
and once we calculate these two
probability
using our
conditional probability theorem given by
newbies
I can
I can check which probability is higher
and whichever probability is higher
suppose I got here 0.4 and I got here
0.6 then I'll classify this email as a
spam email
and that's pretty much what the working
of new basis so the formula looks little
complicated but it is pretty simple
actually all we are doing here is we are
calculating probabilities and based on
that we are assigning a class
so this is how new bees work in general
okay man and and
to give you an example over here just to
finish it off if I say that I have I
have total
600 emails which are regular
400 emails which are spam
and the word free
is occurring 100 times in all the spams
that we have got
all the spam emails I have I have free
happening 100 times and total number of
words are supposed 500
and similarly
if I talk about
a regular email
that has free happening
50 times out of 1000 words
and I can calculate simply probability
like this what is a probability this is
spam
given the word free is there is equal to
100 times freeze happening spam
out of 500 words into probability of and
any email being spam which is which is
400 upon thousand and keep continuing
calculating it and it will give you what
is the probability that any email would
be spam and that's what that's what new
base does actually
so new base algorithm is pretty useful
when you have a text classification that
you want to do for example you want to
do sentiment analysis you have received
thousands of reviews and you want to
know if a particular review
should be tagged as a positive sentiment
or negative sentiment which is very
essential understand this way I might
have thousands of feedbacks coming for a
particular product and overall I want to
understand that if for my customers are
really happy with with the product or or
the feature or not I can think of
building a model which can analyze the
entire data comes up and tells me how
many of them carries
carries positive sentiment how many of
them carries negative sentiment and
eventually it also tells me among all
the positive sentiment reviews that I
have received what are the keywords that
has been used over there what product
features have been mentioned multiple
times similarly of all the negative
reviews that I got which product
features have been used frequently to
give reviews and accordingly I can work
on it and I can better the product or
the services
so so that's what we can do over here
okay and and and in case if I want to
build this model
if I have to build this model so what I
can do here is I can simply go to
my my in our lab we have our lab open
over here I can start
a new notebook I have a data set over
here which I want to show you this is
what the data is
it does mean that uh there is a tweet ID
this is a Twitter data it tells me
there's a tweet ID which is one two
three four five and for each to tweet
there is a sentiment which has been
already
registered probably a manual approach
where we have tagged all the sentiments
whether it's positive or negative and
these are the tweets which have been
which have been mentioned in the data
set
so this is the first tweet then second
and third and what you need to do is you
need to analyze this data
you need to analyze this entire data and
you have to come up with a
classification model which tomorrow can
take any tweet as an input
any to it as an input and can classify
them them as whether they are having
positive sentiment or negative sentiment
okay so that's what the the problem
statement is
so you need to learn from this data how
to classify a tweet into a positive
sentiment or a negative sentiment in an
automated fashion so tomorrow moment a
tweet comes you can get it belongs to
positive sentiment okay what other
keywords have been used we can extract
and we can create a nice dashboard on
top of it which explains that water has
been mentioned in the given data
and for doing that it's not a very
difficult
chance to to build something like this
all we need to know is how many times a
particular word is happening in each of
the review
and I can find out frequency of a
particular word
divided by total number of words
total number of words
and that is called likelihood
and we will calculate likelihood for
each word
and then we will apply our
new base algorithms it will go like this
what is the probability
that a tweet has a positive sentiment
provided
word good is there
provided word better is there provided a
word not is there and so on
and we will calculate this conditional
probability using the new base theorem
that I was just talking about will also
calculate what is the probability that
the same tweet can be on can be having a
negative sentiment provided good is
acting in that better is occurring in
that and not is occurring in that
and whichever probability is higher
I'll classify my tweet as per that
particular class
so what we need to do here we need to
find out what is the likelihood of good
how do we Define that how many times
good is appearing
in all the positive sentiment data and
what is the total number of words which
we have received so far in among all the
positive sentiment data set that has
been given to us similarly here I can
calculate likelihood apply near base and
the model will be in place as simple as
that
okay so this is what name is can do it
for you
now in case if you're wondering
how it is getting done I can explain
that one more time if you want here I'm
just going ahead and I'm applying my
model I want to apply my model on this
and some basic cleaning we do generally
before building the model like I don't
need RT because this word has no impact
on the sentiment whether it's positive
or negative it doesn't matter
similarly the handles which are there
those handles are basically tutor IDs
and that also does not impact whether
the sentiment will be positive and
negative so some basic cleaning has to
be done on this before we proceed and we
build a model so those cleaning again
you can do in Python in a very simple
step you have certain functionalities
which you can apply and you can take
care of it so we import relevant Library
and I can simply say here that Define a
cleaning function
which is generally taught to you in
detail what we are doing over here
in case if you do not associate it don't
worry about it this is just a cleaning
that we can do over here if required and
then we write our
statements which will clean these tweets
and with that clean data we build the
model at the time for the purpose of
demo I'm simply using the entire data
without cleaning it
so what I need to do I need to find how
many times of what is appearing in this
given
tweets which we have
so I'm gonna say here
that uh
CV is equal to count vectorizer that's a
functionality that we have
in our
in our SQL and this is a machine
learning library and here
I Define this and I say that X is equal
to CV Dot
and I'll say fit on
DF dot text
okay so it will just find how many times
a word is appearing over there which
will call it as X underscore
bag of words
and this will be nothing marked
getting
all the
all the count
all the all the count of of each word
which is there and with that we can
simply build the model so now what we're
gonna do here is
I'm gonna say here from
a scale learn okay I need to define y
also so the standard approach of model
building is this if you have been given
data
like in this case we have a single
column and with that we are doing
feature extraction but generally like
talk about credit card
transaction is fraudulent or not so we
will have what was the amount of
transaction
what time it has happened okay what was
the mode of payment what was the
location and along with that I will have
an outcome which is historically defined
that when these values were there where
the transaction was fraudulent or not
yes and no
and the standard procedure of building
model is that you say that this is my X
and this is my y
we separate X and Y X is my input Y is
my output that I want to map to
so here I'm saying my x value is
my x value over here is
this
this text values which were there the
tweets which were there converted into a
frequency
representation how many times a word is
happening that's my X and my y value
would be
NP so what we need to do here is
we need to define y as this NP dot where
if the sentiment
if the sentiment is
equal to positive I'm gonna denote that
case as 1.
and if it is
if it is
no then I'm gonna I'm sorry if it is
negative I'm going to denote that as
zero that's my y value so I Define my X
and Y value that's a that's a standard
procedure and then
what we do is we take the data set we
make two partitions we call it train and
test
on the trained data set
we build the model and on test data set
we evaluate the model standard procedure
for model building
okay so now what we are doing over here
I'm saying from SQL loan
dot model selection
import
train test split I'll split the data
into train and test I'll simply say here
I have
X component for train and test I have y
train n test
and this is equal to train test split X
comma y
and then we can build the model
so I'll say from
sklearn dot newbies
import
multi-normal NB I'll say my model which
can predict
which can predict the
values is going to be this and just
train your model and when we train the
model we simply say fit doesn't matter
which model we are building you simply
say model dot fit that's the same
this is the same function that we use
across any kind of model we are using
and now we have our model is chain just
just matter of four or five lines our
model has been trained
so if you know the right model if you
know the concept model building will not
take much time but but data
pre-processing takes a lot of time in
certain cases and also the fine tuning
of the model takes a lot of time now I
can check how good my model is
on the data set on which it has been
built
so I got 91 accuracy out of 100 cases 91
of them is predicted correctly
then I want to also check how my model
is working out on the test data set
and model accuracy in the test is 83 so
basically what happens what is happening
over here my model performs very well on
the data on which it has been built
that's my train data
but its accuracy is not
not similar on an unseen data and
because the train score is higher then
the test score we have we say this
phenomena as overfitting and overfitting
is a very common problem that you come
across in any of the
any of the machine learning model
and now our focus should be that how do
we take care of this over fitting and
for different model there are different
approaches
so I can work with some smoothing
parameter over here and probably if I if
I clean the data properly this
overfitting will not happen which I know
because I have done this multiple times
in the past
but this was just to give you a little
overview over here so here we got a
model which has an accuracy of 91
percent I want to predict any new tweet
which is coming whether it has a
positive or A negative
or a negative uh sentiment let's try and
see if it's working well or not so I can
say here new
tweet and I'm simply writing a simple
sentence over here I'm going to say here
a simple sentence I'm I'm writing here
not writing as as a tweet and all I'm
simply saying here I got some new tweet
and I'll say NP dot array
and somebody said
that
movie was
excellent
very good that was the first
or tweet I got that's just about some
movie and then I say okay I have I have
another one
I have another one which is a
uh it was very bad experience something
else
okay so I got your Tweet which looks
like this
and I want to apply my model on this and
that this could be any any new tweet
which is coming or it could be some some
other data where you want to see how the
same model can work out on that or not
so all I have to do first we have to
find we have to we have to use our our
count vectorizer to extract feature out
of it so I'm gonna say here that okay
new tweet underscore
features I would say or probably I will
say bag of words is equal to CV Dot
transform
and I'll say here let me tweet
okay so that's what I'll do
so just a second got stuck actually hold
on a second guys
oh hold on a second just running
it happens sometimes yeah no it's just a
problem with my my connection I think
okay over here so what I'm doing over
here is new tweet
Dot
and I'll save here tweet
okay so what we have here is is a new
data set which has these two reviews and
I want to apply my model on top of it so
then I creating bag of words for this
Tweet now every time I get a new data I
need to count how many types of what is
appearing in the given tweet and I need
to map it to the original model and now
I can say model Dot
predict
now I can say predict
on this
on this new tweet bow
and it gives me
and uh
it gives me a prediction as zero and
zero it's just labeling both of them as
as a negative sentiment so basically
this it's it's predicting perfectly but
on this one it is not doing a good job
and as I mentioned that I have done this
in in the past multiple times if I
properly clean this data which takes
little extra time because I need to
process each each sentence kind of a
kind of a iterative way so it takes a
lot of time so if I clean it properly
like I remove unnecessary words from
here I remove certain numbers I remove
symbols and then when I build this model
this will be much much uh
accurate but the idea here is to tell
you that model building might take say
one hour of time maximum probably
because it's just bunch of bunch of code
you are running but fine tuning of the
model which is which is solving this
kind of issue my model is not doing very
well on the on the Unseen data so it is
over fitted solving this is an iterative
task so it starts like this you start
with the data preprocessing in general
I'm talking about where you where you
clean the data and I'm moving directly
to data preprocessing assuming you guys
know that you start with a problem
statement what what is the problem
you're solving then you have data
acquisition and then you have data
preparation and that's the step I'm
talking about so once you do the data
preparation it will have some
transformation some feature engine link
some feature selection and then you
reach the model building process and
once you build the model you realize
model is not very good so what you do
you start fine tuning it change the
configuration of the model it might
become better and if that also is not
really working for you you have to go
back to this data preparation task and
this is a VCS cycle you have to keep
doing this n number of times until your
model becomes really good on the train
data set as well as the test data set so
in Practical scenario what happens is
that if I'm spending and I'm telling you
from my experience if I'm spending 100
hours on a project generally 60 to 70
hours will go in the data task and it's
an intensive task
okay so data task
and probably
10 to 15 hours you will spend in terms
of training the model and depends on the
model also I might I might send a deep
learning model and deep learning model
sometimes might take three four four
hours to train a single single uh
instance so that might be really time
taking but in general I'm talking about
and then another 30 20 to 30 hours
probably roughly I'm saying okay we'll
go back and and we will fine-tune the
model
so 32
15 hours will go into fine tuning of the
model so model building will be a very
small task that we are talking about you
have to focus upon on on data cleaning
feature engineering feature processing
that's a very extensive task
so this is just to give you linear
nutshell the idea is this that we have a
lab where you get the presentation which
is dealt by the trainer over here which
I was explaining you
and then it will be taught to you and
parallely there itself will provide you
some data set and will start working on
it generally the notebooks that we
create it gets created with a lot of
comments so that you understand what we
are doing like here I can write
I can make a comment over here as
removing
stop words
handles
symbols
and numbers
and that's what this function will do so
that tomorrow when you when we share
this notebook with you or if you are
making note parallelly if you are doing
with me parallelly you will know what
why we are writing something and what we
are doing with it so every code will go
like that every line will go that so
like that so basically I'm saying here
is that we'll explain you the concept
entirely and then we'll implement it on
the data and then probably will do a
comprehensive case study on top of it
that's how it will go in the classroom
this was just to give a little
perspective and we had limited time so I
just explained to you what new base
theorem is in in a simple manner a
conditional probability given
and even B has taken place what is the
probability a will take place and and
that's what we calculate here and it's a
an excellent model if you have a text
classification in general and if you
have numerical data then you go for a
gaussian new base which is something
similar but it works with the numerical
later rather than rather than
categorical data so this is what in in
in simple language what new base is and
we just implement it
so Stuart over to you now I think we
have done this one
I had to find the unmute button here
all right thank you very much matendra
and let me go ahead and take back
here we are there we are
and we just did the lesson recap so at
this point
um I'm going to do questions and answers
and this was
you know these sessions in the uh uh
uh boot camp
typically last live classes typically
last four hours so
in today's sample class we could cover
only a small part of what you would be
learning in
one of the sessions
but uh
I think this gives you a flavor for how
the
instruction works
let me
go ahead and start taking questions if
you have questions put them into
the Q a function here
and please stay with us because we're
going to talk a little bit about the
boot camp itself but in the meantime the
first question is will we get the
recorded video we will send you a email
with a link to the recording of this
session
so expect that after
the
probably in about a day or so
looking to see if there are other
questions in the chat oops
wrong button
pulling up the chat
okay
ah
so we have a question is this is a
fairly Advanced lesson for a newbie does
the curriculum have a prerequisite and
this is a good point as I showed you at
the beginning the curriculum this this
is a lesson from the machine learning
module which is about the fifth in the
the series
so this will be far farther along in the
boot camp but um
yes there are there's going to be a
whole bunch of uh
uh preliminary material can you just can
you talk to that um can you speak to
that I'm a Tinder
uh for the prerequisite yeah for how how
somebody would get to the point where
this they'd get to this lesson so it
goes like this uh you will have some
pre-recorded videos which works as a
self-learning module so before we start
we recommend that you go through that
and once we are in the classroom by the
time you reach to this particular module
you will be well accustomed with the
data wrangling process data cleaning
data preparation so that will be covered
entirely in detail stepwise process and
then we reach over here and even this
model that we have been talking about
will be dealt with a proper example in
little bit more detail I would say with
the as as Stuart mentioned will have a
four hour session rather than one hour
session like we are having at the moment
so there will be a prerequisite and
we'll make sure that once you come to
the live classroom if you have any kind
of doubts from the from the from the
pre-recorded videos that you have to go
through that will be dealt first
foundation will be will be created and
then only you will move to this
particular part that's how it goes okay
uh Muhammad asks what language you are
using in the uh cutting example
language was python we were using python
over here but uh the good thing about
these algorithms are that it doesn't
matter which platform you use you will
get the same result it's just that
python is the most sought after language
when it comes to machine learning so we
are relying on that
and one of the things that goes back to
the prerequisite question is that you
notice uh or you may have noted in the
um the curriculum the couple of the
modules of the curriculum focus on
training you in Python and in
applications of python for machine
learning so
um
if you come in without a background in
programming you'll still be able to uh
keep up with the course and get up to
speed so
um
iron uh asks yes
data cleaning is
because I'll read it literally the I
have a doubt that how to clean up the
data like at it's simple and
uh
from the data so I mean I think he's
asking about the actual technique for
removing
um things like the user handles
sure and one more question in addition
to that that I see which is similar to
it is to it if I mean the question is uh
before building a model as current
example we need to clean data instead of
cleaning if you scale that data will
give a proper accuracy stir it so I'll
tell you this uh scaling uh will work
only if you have continuous numerical
data uh this is a text data so Skilling
is normalization is done in a different
way we go for a TF IDF score in instead
of our simple frequency but yeah if you
have to clean the data that's a separate
process scaling is separate you cannot
say that if I'll just just scale it it
will become better it doesn't happen
that way training is a more robust task
which has a a number of steps that you
have to perform and on the other hand
when you're talking about the question
was that what tools techniques we can
use for cleaning the data there are a
number of things that that you have to
go through first on the data before
reach to the model stage so it could be
honest structure data it could be as
simple as missing values or outliers or
probably feature extraction you are
doing or probably you are doing feature
engineering so a lot of things happen at
the data level including the data
cleaning and all
thank you
um
what is the use of the re Library
that is for working with the text Data
if you want to suppose uh substitute
certain text values in a given given
given sentence you can use read now it
is quite intuitive it works with the
pattern so you might say that any number
you find replace it with blank any
symbol you find replace it blank or you
can say that if a word starts with at
the rate
and it doesn't matter what's the length
of the word if it starts with at the
rate remove it so all those kind of
processing when it's required we can use
this Library re stands for rejects it is
also used for information extraction
pretty useful Library
okay uh
uh projector asks about uh techniques
for dealing with overfitting
uh different model will have different
ways of doing it so
so like if I'm doing suppose decision
tree or fitting can be taken care by
pruning up the trees like I can I can
work on the depth of the tree I can work
with the split of the tree the guinea
values or if I'm doing suppose support
Vector machines then I have their
parameters C I have parameter gamma
which I need to manually configure
similarly if I go to deep learning I
will have number of layers number of
nodes the learning rate so different
models will have different ways of
handling the overfitting problem and
that's where people should focus upon
also learning a model is not sufficient
you have to learn how to fine tune it
and that's where taking care of
overfitting will come and every model
will have its own way of dealing with it
thank you um
sirov would like a reminder of where
knife base is used and what its
limitations are her newbies is is
generally used for text classification
it doesn't mean that we cannot apply for
a apply on a on a on a structured data
account numerical data but generally we
use for text classification it works
well and for numerical data we have
better model than this uh assumptions
are that it's called new because uh uh
presence of think about email when I'm
calculating the probability it is not
bothered about presence of other words
it just focuses on one word at a time so
they're very name so the idea is this
that assumption is this that that these
features are totally independent of each
other and whenever this uh this this uh
kind of situation is there we can use
new base and as I said use it for text
classification gives pretty good result
her we had just a few more questions
here so Harish asked does underfitting
mean that the model is accurate
under fitting means model has a has a
low score on the data on which it has
been built which is trained data but it
has a relatively higher score on unseen
data which is the test data it means the
data split is not good you have to
reshuffle the data split it again or
probably add more data points to your
training data it will be taken care
underfitting is not a big challenge
okay
um
we have a question
uh from another uh who asks he's trying
to learn about swarm intelligence well
that covered in the boot camp
and no we are not doing that actually
like that's a very Niche and specific
area but this is a building block for
that once you go through these
techniques then probably you can start
building knowledge on that as well
thank you and
uh
uh remember she asks a different
question how difficult is it to train
with image data rather than uh verbal or
numeric
okay there was a one question earlier
also an image classification which I
missed out so let me tell you image data
when we work with we have something
called convolutional neural network
which has been designed to extract
features from the images and then learn
from it and do the classification as
well that gives a pretty good result and
has become more or less a very standard
model for doing any kind of image
classification or object detection in
fact you also get a lot of pre-trend CNN
which you can directly apply on your
problem statement the idea there would
be like if I'm doing image
classification suppose two classes for
each class probably I need thousand
images a piece and then I can build a
network and say if if everything is is
up to the level then it doesn't take
much time probably an hour or two is
sufficient if you have good machine
but the problem will happen when you
have certain classification to be done
which is which is very uh complex like
it could be finding uh finding uh any
kind of error in a in a fabric actually
so that will be very very uh minute and
you need to build really deep Network so
that might take time so sometimes you
might have a problem where you're
training for three four hours also and
after that you realize that model has
overfitted so another three four hours
will go for every iteration that you are
running so that takes time and that's
why we need good machines for that gpus
and everything
okay
and we had several questions here about
uh dealing with overfitting and
underfitting which is something that
you'll learn in the in the course but
we've
covered a little bit of that in Sample
lesson and we will be sending a link to
this recording so that you'll be able to
review it
uh I'm gonna tender spoke about
um
you also have a question and we'll get
into
um it's an interesting question which is
how what is the best way for a developer
to get from beginner to Advanced
field of machine learning and data
science
uh beginners to advance it starts with
the fundamentals of of entirely machine
learning start with the basic algorithms
Master them and what we do generally is
we give you a lot of case studies to
work upon on each module and we tell you
what are the advantages disadvantages of
a model how do you fine tune it further
and then what will be going forward you
have to do so start with the simple
linear models then start with the
non-linear models and gradually you move
towards the Deep learning that's what
the process would be and remember these
uh
algorithms would be based on certain
mathematical optimization algorithms so
some mathematical intuition will also be
required which generally we deal in the
classroom we give you the entire
mathematical intuition how it works so I
would say start with vector algebra at a
very basic level and then gradually move
to towards your machine learning
algorithm in fact applied data science
with python which is a part of this
entire course curriculum deals with
vector algebra it deals with the your
Calculus it talks about integral
differential calculus that we we have to
use in our uh models so that's how you
should go about in general
and I want to take one last question
because I find it interesting which is
uh from Muhammad which
uh he works in sensors in remote health
and wants to classify the sensed
information
to determine if it's faulty or not so
what type of
classification model applies in that
kind of problem
okay reading the the statement that you
have mentioned Muhammad it looks like an
imbalanced data imbalance data is such
where you will have lot of cases where
there will be no fault and only few
cases which will have fault so it
becomes a little more trickier problem
because you do not have ample example
for one of the class so in this
situation uh we we try multiple models
to start with we also try stacked models
like multiple model is stuck into a
single entity we also do we also see how
to take your imbalance aspect of it how
to penalize any any any wrong thing
wrong predictions which are happening so
this is one part and if it doesn't work
that way also then we go to anomaly
detection like anomalia detection will
try and understand what kind of uh
anomalies are there in the data and
those anomalies could lead to
identifying a faulty uh class that you
are looking so depends on the data but
looking at it I feel it's an imbalanced
data problem that you will come across
okay do you mind if we take a one or two
more yeah go ahead go ahead okay uh
Rasheed asks if you need a better CPU
and you're training a data Text data or
do you use a GPU and then just as a
preliminary for for this course
everything is done on the learning
management system so you have a virtual
machine assigned that you you don't have
to worry about your own
set up at home but in the general case
if you were setting up a
machine Learning System would you focus
on the CPU or the or the GPU as a
different
depends on the sorry sorry was saying
something no no go ahead
I'm saying depends on the on the problem
if you have relatively smaller set of
data you can get away with CPU GPU is
required if if the data size is huge and
even the model that you are using is
really complex model with with deep
layers inside it so then it becomes
difficult to
train it on over the CPU in the in the
in the in the prescribed time and that's
where GPU comes into the picture we can
parallelize the training like by the
time we finish one iteration with the
help of GPU we can have multiple threats
going on so depends on the situation
like so far if you ask me uh uh in last
few years we have been exclusively
working on the image classification
object detection problem so we have been
using machines which has which has GPU
support to it because we have to reduce
the training time even for the NLP
processes but some of the machine
learning model that we have built could
be well dealt with with the CPU itself
so it depends on the situation okay
thanks and the last question um
from Aaron who has asked a couple of
times about the problem of dealing with
25 000 rows of data
and how would you tackle that in terms
of
selecting what to use for test data and
what to use for training data
000 data points it's not much in terms
of in terms of size in a sense it will
be easily handling it and generally we
want to keep up uh
higher proportion of data for the
training purpose so 70 80 percent if you
ask me 25 000 data points go with 75
percent if you train 25 to test or
probably you can do a k-fold uh cross
validation also where you can actually
put them into multiple groups and with
each group you train one by one so
that's a different process of it but
that wouldn't be a problem 25 000 data
points is sufficient and make a 75-25
split it will work
thanks very much okay so that covers
the questions that's uh we're out at the
Accord the end of our session here so
what I'm going to do is return to
and mentioned the boot camp from which
this lesson was drawn this is a six
month fully online program
and it's designed for people who are
working professionals so you only have
to dedicate about
10 hours per week it includes as I
mentioned live classes generally on the
weekends not not every module in the
curriculum has live classes but for the
ones that do
you would end up with four hours on
Saturday four hours on Sunday
and that would be the same kind of live
instruction that you got a sample of
today uh with integrated Labs with the
going through the exercises and you'd
have your own
uh lab and Pla project platform to do
the work on so that you could replicate
what
I'm a tender and the other instructors
are teaching you and do the exercises
yourself so that you get a Hands-On
learning
um you also through that process build
up a portfolio of examples of experience
that you show off
potential future employers and
again the rest of the time as amateendra
said when you're working on projects
when you're working on
uh or looking at
the port materials ebooks and videos you
do that on your own time anytime 24 7 so
that you
um can fit that into whatever schedule
you have available
so somebody
asked about prerequisites you only need
a basic understanding of mathematics and
programming Concepts
you do have to have a
this is the boot camp actually you don't
have to have a bachelor's degree and
then two or more years of work
experience is preferred but not required
so and we also provide career assistance
after you graduate from the boot camp so
for an additional six months you get
help with uh exclusive job portal resume
review and rewrite service and
one-on-one interview prep
so all of that in the
program so I'm going to ask a series of
quick questions if I may
um first one is
uh
sorry
to
move on past that one
let's ask this first question if you're
watching on a streaming service you can
put A B C or D in your comments but this
one is how much experience do you have
I'll close this in about three seconds
and here we go
so about uh
third of our audience or people are
currently students again this is the
Caltech boot camp the actual requirement
for this is a high school diploma
bachelor's degree so this is open to
pretty much everybody who's here today
show you the result here
and
next I'm going to ask two questions one
after the other
first one is are you interested in
enrolling in the program
based on what you've seen in the sample
lesson and what we've talked about today
and this is not a commitment you know
you don't have to enroll if you answer
yes but we're just curious to know you'd
be interested
I'll leave this open for another three
seconds to
one
about two-thirds of the audience are
interested in that so I will ask the
other question here
how soon would you see yourself uh for
those of you who answered yes how soon
did you see yourself enrolling
and we do cohorts of this program fairly
pretty much on them every month basis
so there's next cohort starting
pretty quickly after this session
again I'll close this in three
two one
and I'm looking at about half of the
audience are interested in
joining either immediately or fairly
soon thereafter
so
I'll show that to you
and
lastly
if you would like to get a certificate
for attending this session
this sample lesson today
just a proof of attendance it doesn't
certify anything else except proof of
attendance or if you would like us to
reach out to you and answer questions
help you with enrollment
um I do want to mention that there will
be a discount offer
and you'll be able to ask about the
price of the program you'll get a 500
dollar
discount from the program cost
if you mentioned that you attended this
webinar
so
we'll be sending all that information in
the follow-up email as well
but let me watch this question are you
uh interested in having us reach out or
would you like to get a
proof of attendance for the session here
and
all right and I'll end the poll
about 55 percent of our audience said
that they would like
us to reach out which we will do after
this session so thank you all very much
and I want to thank uh amitendra for
attending I'm going to put into the chat
box right now
um the email address that you see along
with the URL
for the program
web page and what you'll be able to do
there is
check the
course price
and the detailed curriculum
and get more information including
testimonials from people who've taken
the course
that's in the chat box right now so
I want to thank everybody for being here
and thanks again to amatendra for being
so generous with your time and your
knowledge
thank you Stuart
okay and we'll see you all
we hope to welcome you into the simply
learning Caltech learning community so
again that ends our welcome today